We're gonna talk about style.
You know, it was just Fashion Week
and from Milan to Paris, and the New York Times reports
that one shape was everywhere, Drew,
and it was the suit.
And it's not just Gucci and Versace.
There's a huge trend of people
taking off their sweatpants, ahem, I'm looking at you.
Because I wear them too much, I know.
Every morning, it's headed towards sweatpants.
Every day, even on dates
and then my friends get mad at me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like, well, they should know the real deal.
But, but, look what's happening.
Thank you. (Ross chuckles)
I'm like, if you're not into Netflix and takeout,
we should just not bother.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Yes.
I like you in sweatpants, I'm just...
This was Fashion Week, you know.
All right, so what's the latest in fashion, Rossy?
Well, it's suits for women.
Check out Zendaya.
Here's Zendaya.
Sandra, all right. (crowd cheers and claps)
These bold colors.
Sandra Oh, Sophia Bush, that is...
Okay, your sweatpants are cute, but hello.
Yeah, no, I can't.
It doesn't compare with that, those three gorgeous women.
But you show up, you do show up for fashion
and in fact check out this fashion maven
at New York Fashion Week.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Yup, I'm wearing...
Hello, that's you in a suit.
You're on trend.
Oh good.
Christian Siriano put me in that suit.
Thank you, Christian.
I love...
He is such a good friend.
He gets me out of the house.
He gets me outta sweatpants.
Yeah.
All right. Well, this is interesting.
I recently did my first Zoom date
and it wasn't as weird as I thought it was gonna be.
I think because we've all been so accustomed
to Zoom at work and you know, with friends
and we're all sort of Zoom literate right now.
Yeah, we speak Zoom.
We speak Zoom.
Well, this story really spoke to me
'cause it's about the Zoom world.
The Albuquerque Journal reports
that animal welfare department there
had started a virtual dating service
to link pets and potential owners.
Come on, cute. (crowd awws)
People looking to adopt can Zoom date
with a pet first to check out their vibe
before they meet in person.
And the foster parents will operate the Zoom
for the puppy or the kitty
because you know, they have no hands.
Oh yeah, well, they can't.
Except for if you're Douglas, my dog,
who gets behind the monitor here.
Look, these are the potential pets you can meet.
Aww.
And I mean, how cute. There's my dog Douglas.
Oh my gosh.
Look at his paw, he's wearing a wig too.
(crowd laughs)
There he goes, there he goes, he's typing.
(Ross laughs)
Yeah, he's working the monitor there.
So unless, you know, unless you're Douglas
you're gonna need a foster parent to man the keyboard.
And if all goes well, then you can meet up
at the shelter to have an in-person date
and see if the fit works as well as it did on Zoom.
What do you think about this, Rossy?
Well, this is such a duh, of course thing, right?
You know, there's animals in need
all over the country, all over the world
and now you can Zoom with them
or FaceTime or as they call it muzzle time, (laughs)
one on one, but what a great opportunity.
You know, if you can't find the right animal near you,
maybe it's across the country and this connects you.
So I love this.
I just think the next time you say,
how was your Zoom con, you can say he was a real dog.
It actually could be a good thing.
(upbeat theme music)